mon café [ __ ]
non mais c'est dingue mon cap town
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous cas c'est un cothias a su
ça va tout le monde veut bien il ya bien
bon coup le petit débris de la semaine
dernière thierry vous avez pleuré lors
de la dernière mission en écoutant une
chanson d'aurico macias moi aussi ça me
fait toujours le même effet quand
j'entends le mendiant de l'amour j'ai
envie de chialer pas pour les mêmes
raisons que vous
alors quand on regarde le plateau ce
soir c'est bien c'est beau c'est vrai
alors le problème c'est qu'on sait pas
si c'est une émission de télé ou un
congrès de dentistes tellement il ya de
dents blanches mais c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
frédéric lopez c'est la classe il
inventait plein de super concept
d'émission rendez vous en terre inconnue
c'est lui un tu sais tu prends une star
et tu l'emmènes dans un pays où il
voulait pas aller à la base il l'a fait
avec arthur frédéric il a emmené au
pérou en belgique ce n'est pas de sa
faute
alors le rituel c'est bandé les yeux de
la star à l'aéroport pour cacher la
destination bon sauf avec gilbert
montagné fonctionnement non mais à la
place si l'ua et bouche et le nez et
non d'ailleurs et si jamais vous l'effet
rendez vous en terre inconnue avec
thierry lui bander pas les yeux parce
que ça va lui rappeler ses soirées aux
chandelles
alors que les flops l'aise vous venez
nous voir pour votre nouvelle émission
sur france 2 où il y aura des humoristes
quatre invités de 3,4 un groupe de
musique
comment ça se passe siri vous allez vous
laisser marcher sur les couilles
jusqu'au bout de l'émission
on attendait
natacha polony aussi c'est beau c'est
une rousse avec un air stricte habillant
en cuir et qui est de droite bref la
fille cachée de mylène farmer et d'alain
juppé
[Applaudissements]
alors la tâche et vous allez présenter
une nouvelle émission sur paris première
polonium que vous enregistrez robin
thierry à l'époque bain de minuit
c'était aux bains douches oui j'appelle
l'avocat tout de suite ou comment ça se
passe au niveau des droits d'émission
obtint alors votre mari natacha et
critique gastronomique et j'ai lu
quelque part que dans votre propre
maison nous vous n'avez pas le droit de
pénétrer dans votre propre cuisine mais
c'est pas la mienne d'ailleurs c'est sa
cuisine du coup frédéric voulais pas
faire un terrain connu chez mobalpa et
natacha
christophe beaugrand christine programme
vous êtes animateur de secretstory
christophe vous avez dit présenter
secretstory c'était votre voeu le plus
cher
j'ai dit ça oui
alors racontera très en beauté canari
dans la mine et les votre voeu le plus
cher je vous dis j'ai pas envie de
savoir c'est quoi votre voeu le plus
pourri
[Applaudissements]
alors d'ailleurs thierry pour les
participants secretstory j'aurais rami
bah ouais j'ai trouvé un secret déjà
c'est je fais les meilleures audiences
de canal plus et personne ne le sait
mesdames et messieurs ma mission ici et
de poser les questions trop con que
thierry ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
posez on va commencer avec frédéric
lopez alors frédéric dans votre jeunesse
vous avez déménagé pas moins de dix neuf
fois est ce que vous savez qu'il ya des
gitans beaucoup plus sédentaires que
vous
[Applaudissements]
christophe beaugrand que vous avez
participé à l'émission au splatch sur
tf1 c'était quoi le plus dur le plongeon
de 10 mètres ou se balader en cible de
25 millions de gens sébastien maio large
quand même un bon milliard une couille
qui dépassait de
natacha polony alors natacha vous aviez
déjà atteint votre taille adulte à l'âge
de 12 ans vous avez d'autres points
communs avec mimie mathy ou pas
bon thierry j'y vais sans facebook
franchement je pense qu'on retrouvera la
semaine prochaine les corrections de ne
rien rater de in a l'habitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux